bonjour david alors nouvelle journée de
grève pour les salariés d'edf pour
quelle raison les syndicats s'opposent à
ce projet recul est bien pour ça olivier
il faut d'abord remonté deux ans en
arrière la dislocation d'edf en trois
entités pour privatiser certaines
activités à de la firme electric aurait
été actée par le gouvernement et
bruxelles un accord que pointent du
doigt à syndicats et l'opposition
accusant l exécutif de vouloir faire
passer en douce ce projet hercules un
projet je cite de démantèlement du
service public de l'électricité alors
pour bien comprendre
edf serait à diviser par 3 df bleu pour
le nucléaire français qui resterait
public
en revanche les deux autres filières edf
vert pour les énergies renouvelables et
edf azur pour le secteur hydroélectrique
serait en partie ouvert à la concurrence
puisque mise en bourse
conséquence de cette césure edf serait
rentable pour les actifs est privé en
parallèle elle deviendrait coûteux pour
le contribuable
une situation qui impacterait
directement nos portefeuilles et
entraînerait une flambée à des prix
d'électricité
écoutez à ce sujet alors en heredia
secrétaire fédéral de la cgt énergie
actuellement il ya des capitaux privés
ont demandé du rendement d'une part mais
aussi demandé derrière ben voilà est ce
qu'une amélioration du fonctionnement en
terme en termes de coût je dis comme ça
et donc ils vont serrer la vis et donc
ça aura des impacts sur les usagers au
niveau de la qualité de fourniture d'une
part mais aussi près semblablement sur
les tarifs d'acheminement d'électricité
donc sur les factures des usagers au
final ça c'est une quasi-certitude
attaque le premier ça sera mécaniquement
l'augmentation des factures parce qu'à
partir du moment où on cloisonne on
rajoute des interfaces donc qui dit
rejeter des interfaces d'idées couche
supplémentaire c'est ce qu'on a remarqué
nous depuis 2004 déjà lors qu'on vend
sur ajouter encore et puis après
derrière
à partir du moment où cloisonné que non
mais on cristallise la production comme
le dire un modèle bleu des factures au
service de l'ensemble des fournisseurs
et des ans génère une feinte de
concurrence avec
des terres des tarifs d'achat pour les
fournisseurs qui vont être flic c est
après les fournisseurs pourront donner
eux des tarifs libres comme il le désire
d'ailleurs et donc on va se retrouver
avec une flambée des tarifs automatique
cette date du 10 février a choisi par
les syndicats pour ce nouveau
rassemblement devant l'assemblée
nationale est symbolique puisque le
président d'edf et bruno le maire seront
auditionnés par les parlementaires
concernant ce projet hercules cet
après-midi et david une question très
concrète c'est cette journée de grève
est-ce qu'elle va avoir un impact sur la
production électrique en cette période
de grand froid là tous constaté est ce
que ça pourrait s'avérer problématique
pour les consommateurs effectivement
c'est le risque
olivier c'est surtout l'objectif des
syndicats cette sixième journée de
mobilisation
elle devrait être encore une fois
devrait concerner avait encore une fois
une bonne partie à des effectifs
à titre d'exemple lors des précédents
grave près de 30% des salariés avaient
suivi ce mouvement et avait
automatiquement fait baisser la
production électrique est la production
et en a déjà tendu en cette période de
pandémie on peut donc s attendre
effectivement des coupures dans
certaines régions un outil
malheureusement indispensable à la lutte
sociale pour accroître la pression sur
le gouvernement mais aussi sur bruxelles
l an dernier on se souvient également
que pour protester contre la réforme des
retraites des ouvriers d'edf avait
temporairement privés à des à la cour le
courant des dizaines de milliers
d'usagers cet après midi une forte
mobilisation est attendue devant
l'assemblée nationale afin de contester
la privatisation à terme d'une partie de
df une mobilisation qu'on suivra bien
évidemment sur rt france merci à vous
david pour ces précisions